the scariest aspect of the science
shutdown was the potential permission
this movement gave itself if science is
racist the movement can or must be
unscientific to avoid being racist was
this intellectual looting the ultimate
goal of the science shut down yeah so we
did I think it was episode 22 maybe in
which we talked a lot about the shut
down stem and yes certainly their hand
in hand and you know what is what is the
benefit of shutting down stem is it you
know honestly to get a stall reflect on
our internalized and externalize racism
or is it actually go after science and
logic and enlightenment values
altogether and you know oh there's
nothing on the black lives matter
webpage that I saw I haven't looked at
all of their sub pages that goes
directly after stem but they're proudly
going after the nuclear family and
promoting you know trans lives over you
know other people's lives and they were
hand in hand with shut down stem just
not formally it's all of a piece yeah it
is all of a piece so I'm reminded of
your adviser arnold Kluge and his very
wise file cabinet yes his office the
note on the file cabinet said it's about
power and limited resources stupid so
all of these moves I don't know why
people were scared of him the this is
all about power all of it the pulling
down of the statues the redefining of
the terms the setting up a black only
section of the lawn in the Chas all of
the chop sorry just I'm sorry
all these things are about power getting
science magazine in nature magazine to
broadcast shut down stem it's all about
power
and it all comes with like a little
fallback position so as at Evergreen
where they did want every single white
person to leave campus for a day
they did have a 200-seat workshop which
couldn't possibly accommodate all of us
so they could just say well it wasn't
for everybody you're overreacting right
so anyway these things the little
protective fallback for shutdown stem is
well it's linked for a day but no didn't
you just give science magazine reacting
right you're that productive every
single day can't you just take a day
Brett to reflect on your internal racism
can you take a day taking plenty of
really clear that you're not going to
take that yeah I think if anyone has it
same but anyway yes the don't be fooled
by the little fallback positions it's
nonsense
shut down stem really is about shutting
down stem and yes this is rationalizing
the saying of illogical things the
foregoing of analytical tools that's
what they're doing
[Music]